Good news! In 2016, poverty in the United
States – no matter how you measured it –
fell close to its all-time low, with
especially good numbers for African
Americans and Hispanics. But with more
than 40 million Americans still
qualifying for food stamp benefits, we
surely can do better. The problem is a
shrinking labor force. Unemployment is
low, but many healthy people – especially
men – have dropped out of the labor force
entirely, and rely on the social safety
net for support. If you're healthy and
you choose not to work, there's only so
much the government can do to keep you
out of poverty. Thankfully, 2018 should be
a good year for people to get into work
and out of poverty. Employers are hiring,
paying more – even hiring people returning
from prison – and offering paid leave
packages and enhanced training. Safety
net programs like food stamps are
beginning to focus on pushing people
into work, not just signing them up for
benefits. These efforts mean even more
people will earn their way out of
poverty in 2018, and if you're truly
focused on enhancing dignity for all
Americans, that's what matters most.
How do you think we're doing fighting poverty? Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.